last thing what happened with sharp last
night man man that [__] was uh
he was I can say for me
I was he was being loyal
to no jumper because he's still over
there and I was just trying to break
down like
there's a ceiling for us there and it
felt like you feel like you two were
having a civil conversation is friends
that was respectful
the people around me now pun Trey
um hold there's a lot of other people
that you don't see on camera they're
tired of like having to hold back on
account of me you know I mean because
it's a lot of like you know Shady things
that have happened in business and stuff
like that where you know I try to look
the other way and they're like nah you
know it's time like we can't do this we
can't do that and
if you feel like your boy is being done
wrong and you're explaining to somebody
why that is wrong see one thing that
sharp said in that when we was having
that conversation he said you had
Leverage
I'm not looking at something that
somebody I consider friend is leveraged
with our relationship or business at the
end of the day I'm looking at it like
[__] if you my brother if I feel
betrayed I don't give a [__] how much
money I'm I'm losing out on I don't care
about how much the situation may affect
my livelihood I move off of morals and
principles so if somebody is blankly
going on platforms and saying like hey
you don't like me and T rails progress
because you think that it now is too
uncontrollable and it's too big now to
where you can't put us on contract why
have leverage like that that means that
you're always going to keep us a step
below no no I think you have the power
to do that obviously now that you get
all now you get that full context yeah
talking about it more but I do think
that like
I think sharp was just kind of
presenting an angle of
had you guys came in and be like hey
we're about to [__] leave double our
pay or you know what I'm saying like but
again I just think that but it's not
about the money bro no no I get that I
get that so I just I but I think that
like you know when you're talking to
people about [__] like they're just he's
just sharing one perspective I just
think I was like I was like oh you guys
were getting like it was a civil
conversation but even even and then our
guy pun yeah but even though it comes in
like a wrecking ball OT wasn't feeling
the conversation either yeah because
people like like me I got my grandma's
heart I listen to everybody I hear
everybody out and I try to see the good
and everything and the people around me
they watch me get burned six million
[__] times right and they're tired of
that [__] so that's where that
aggression comes from it's not
necessarily oh sharp you the bad guy
because a lot of people were like oh
well maybe you you feel like you made a
bad decision no I stand on every
decision that I do and the people around
me they've been waiting to just be
Unleashed because they've been seeing
behind the scenes stuff that they didn't
like and I still look at it like you
know what
uh maybe this maybe this maybe that nah
bro this is what it really is it's cut
and dry it's in your face and if you
can't process that
and see where you're wronged in a
situation then hey can't expect nobody
else if you were us if you were us what
would you have done oh I would have did
what I told you all to do exactly but I
think that my my whole thing was is the
one thing I saw last night
um that
worried me was it it was like
I don't want y'all to go down that path
of like just [__] like like it felt like
okay obviously you and and sharp are
having a civil conversation which is not
necessarily the greatest thing for views
but what is a good thing for views is
putting the punstigator on to go crazy
on Sharp and like my thing is is a
Sharps like your genuine homie like you
guys hit him to talk about what was
going on you know what I'm saying he
decided to hop on give you his
perspective whether or not you agree
with his perspective it was responsible
but just being respected that was like
that was real it was raw right it was it
was curious and honestly like did you
think you putting punt on three-way with
sharp was gonna go well
um I didn't even think about it you were
just like hey he's calling like I'm like
honestly that was like we just hit the
100K Mark we was having fun everybody's
just having a good time right I thought
I thought me personally
it was going to go a different type of
way right see I think sharp took it
personal when he said well I'm still at
no jumper is it [__] me when it was like
NADA we got a problem with anybody we're
gonna say [__] you right you don't own
no jumper you feel me if my homies is on
hey ad got done wrong we not [__]
with them that don't mean his [__]
Almighty that don't mean as [__] sharp
that don't mean as [__] Flaco we still
talk to everybody that's on there Flacco
was just you know what I'm saying I
still have a conversation with people
that don't know jumper did you call him
after the uh I talked to him after the
stream and I told him I was just like
listen bro like the way that the people
feel about certain situations like we're
not dumb we know what time it is like if
it's a great business decision for you I
don't expect you to leave right that get
your money if you getting paid what you
getting paid over there get that bread
yeah you know what I'm saying OG suicide
that's my uncle you feel me I told him
stay over there right if they're taking
care of you and they doing it that's
something in your best interest go ahead
and do that I'm not gonna get in between
you and money and I don't expect
everybody to make a decision that I made
Tyrell moved off the just pure loyalty
he said he didn't want to do it without
me I said the same thing if Tyrell was
out we wasn't going to do it when Dino
was talking about leaving if do not
would have left before that we had a
chance to leave we would have left a
long time ago because we like [__] the
camaraderie and what we have we can't do
this with other people bro right and we
could do something but it's still not
going to be the same in that magic and
we got to stick together well I think
the timing worked out man so next
Wednesday will be the first yes new show
new food show coming the whole universe
is coming proud of y'all man shame on
you I can't wait to see uh what y'all
got coming bruh yeah shame on you shame
on you next Wednesday the 29th 29th man
there it is appreciate y'all fellas
appreciate it yes appreciate it boom